say let not your heart be troubled my
heart is troubled our fellow americans
are in deep trouble tonight behind enemy
lines our friends our allies are in deep
trouble behind enemy lines you know
leave no man or woman behind well great
britain and france to their credit they
sent in troops to kabul to escort
citizens from kabul successfully to the
airport why haven't we we have the best
military fighting force on the face of
the earth yeah americans now can't get
to the airport held hostage and they're
behind enemy lines day six joining us
now with more former secretary of state
mike pompeo
i know you have p plenty of contacts in
the region
without asking specific questions which
i will get to i want you to give your
best assessment of the situation on the
ground and what potential options you
might see to get our fellow americans
and allies out safely
well sean you pretty much catalogued the
chaos and the tragedy of these past six
days we now have americans trapped
behind enemy lines
today what president biden said frankly
made it worse i didn't hear a single
thing from him today that would have
given comfort to those families there's
still no plan to get these americans
back i didn't hear a single thing that
would give comfort to the very allies
you spoke about i've heard from people
in the region they are frightened by the
american collapse the american collapse
of temerity and strength and power that
we demonstrated for four years that had
frankly kept the taliban at bay and
prevented precisely what you're seeing
happening today and i didn't hear a
single thing that would frighten a
single taliban who thinks there's any
risk that this administration will post
any cost on them for their activities
for what they're doing to americans
today and holding them hostage not
permitting them to get into the airport
in kabul so that we can get them home to
their families this is a debacle of
significant proportions we haven't seen
anything like this in the united states
in an awfully long time
america has the tools to fix this our
military could certainly figure out a
way to go get these folks back and to
destroy some of these billions of
dollars in equipment that we left behind
but it's going to take american resolve
and leadership and president biden has
refused to show this for the entire time
they could have done this is all
preventable the biden white house was
warned they were warned by their own
people they were worn weeks ago this was
inevitable i'm told that for example the
cia pulled their people out over six
weeks ago they all saw it coming here's
my question now the biden administration
has been trying to place blame on both
you and president trump i happen to know
a little bit more than the average
person uh because your plan was based
one on conditions on the ground
before anything else and also confirmed
by the president and mark meadows you
are right up to your eyeballs as part of
these negotiations before any
negotiations take place to the extent
that you're able to share
my understanding is donald trump on the
phone with the taliban leader was clear
and unambiguous
if you don't follow if we have a deal
and you violate any aspect of that deal
let me tell you the might and of the
united states military will be brought
to bear in ways that the world has never
seen before
something to that effect is that true
sir
sean that's absolutely true i was on
that phone call uh when he spoke with
mueller berater he told him very plainly
we set down a set of conditions we have
every expectation that you will comply
with those conditions if you don't
comply though with those conditions we
will reign american power on top of you
indeed sean from time to time they
pushed a little too far to checkpoint or
took an action that was inconsistent
with our understanding and we crushed
them we applied american power a
deterrence model that said america is
strong you're weak you're going to do
the things we want you to do and until
you do we're not going to comply with
the promises we made look sean as much
as we want to get everybody out we
didn't get to the point where the
conditions were right to do precisely
that we we went down from 15 000 to 2500
and we maintained the order that had
been in afghanistan we were successful
in doing that now they have twice as
many almost three times as many american
military in there and it's chaos this is
because of failed leadership this is
because the taliban think that they face
no risk from this president of the
united states that threat was so real
that for over a year not a single
american was killed in afghanistan and
and the taliban understood what the
consequences would be
uh my question is we watched 10 percent
of the the country get taken over by the
taliban 20 percent 30 percent 40 percent
five weeks ago the state department said
that kabul will be overthrown where's
the sense of urgency at that moment to
immediately identify every american
where they are and extract every
american the logistics to get it done as
expeditiously as possible why did that
not happen mr secretary
sean is pretty incomprehensible to me i
i can't explain the absence of planning
at first i said they planned and they
said they couldn't have planned for it i
can't explain where when they saw this
they didn't do the right thing for the
american people i can assure you that
president trump and i would have done
that every time the taliban pushed we
pushed right back we had a deterrence
model place when the taliban pushed here
10
20
we withdrew we withdrew the support that
was needed to make sure that we could
get these americans out from behind what
was to become enemy lines to make sure
that we could support our allies the
promises that we had made to them all of
these things the things that the whole
world is seeing now american leadership
crumble in the face of this taliban
might this is this has got ramifications
that will last an awfully long time sean
i hope this president is determined
enough to begin to take back the
capacity to exert american influence in
this region and deal with the taliban in
a way that president trump and i did for
so long mr secretary thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else